hello everyone we are talking about
civilization 6 i'm here with Mike mihari
Mike you and I both got to play roughly
150 turns of this game I am new to this
whole franchise and you are a longtime
fan is that correct yeah so ization 5 is
one of my favorite games especially once
the expansion's gods and kings and brave
new world came out and coincidentally
the team making civil'zation 6 with the
team that made those expansions so i
have really high hopes for six
especially after playing 150 turns i
came away with pretty positive feelings
Mike obviously there are a lot of
changes with this game but we have
broken out five major changes and we're
going to talk about them first off we
have unstacked cities Mike or expansive
empires when you go ahead and kind of
describe what this is yeah this is the
big one similar to how civ 5 is known
for unstacking military units on the
same tile you know expanding them
outwards civics expands city so no
longer do you have one city tile with
your palace your university your Harbor
anything you want to build now you have
these districts that you build so say
you build a campus that's going to be
its own tile apart from the palace tile
so you will build a campus and then that
will allow you to build the scientific
structures like the universities which
will obviously you know boost your
science and help you research new
technologies that's progressing you
through the game if you're a military
minded player which I'm not normally but
it's still a big part of the game when
you're attacking city you can look and
say oh that's their scientific district
that's also a civilization that has a
ton of advanced technology that we don't
have we should take out that district
first and then you know lay seeds to the
rest of it afterwards but also if you're
if it's your city you can have an
encampment which essentially you can
build military units from there as well
and not just your Palace tile so you can
kind of like start flanking people but
this also makes you have to read the map
more right because you know certain
places like the aquaduct you need to you
want to build next to a river right
there are certain districts to get
adjacency bonuses so if you're you know
campus is next to an aqua doctor for
instance I'm not sure if that's the
specific example I'm looking for that'll
boost the science output of that
district so you really want to make sure
you place your cities in the right spot
this was always a concern but now you're
not just worried about farms or markets
or mine you're worrying about these
actual huge city districts that you're
gonna have to
about down the road so then we have
active research which is essentially
like a side task you can do to
efficiently tackle different areas of
research right yeah so this just pretty
much it's exactly what it sounds it's
your proactively you know pursuing
certain technologies in that say you
might be researching pottery but then
you build a quarry and that's going to
give you a significant boost to your
masonry research and then that's going
to make you switch to masonry so you can
build it faster this decreases the time
it takes to research each technology so
whereas before in previous sieve cams
you were just increasing each city's
science output to decrease the time it
would take to research each new
technology this actively lets you cut it
in half sometimes or even one time I
just completed it complete because I you
know I finished like I built three farms
and then it just completed a research
for me and then I had an extra one right
there and it also just ensures that
there's a lot more to think about each
turn right there are so many more
options readily available moving on to
dynamic diplomacy what is this about
Mike yeah so this is a something
previous civilization games have always
tried you know like to make these
leaders characters that you can kind of
predict or be surprised when they do
something outside the behavior that you
thought they'd established so each
leader in the game has one so you can
kind of get into a game be like oh ok
I've got kin chuang I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing that right but he's the
Chinese leader he historically is really
inclined toward building wonders and
kind of like increasing the culture of
his civilization so in my game I was
building a lot of Wonders and he was
kind of getting annoyed at it because I
was encroaching on you know his
playstyle and he eventually declared war
him he denounced me declare war on me
because I built the Hanging Gardens I
built the pyramids I built Stonehenge
and he was like all right that's too
much but also each leader has a hidden
agenda because one thing that they're
trying to do with civ 6 is make sure
that each playthrough is different so
that's where the hidden agendas come in
if you see roosevelt is building a ton
of settlers or Catherine de Medici is
building a ton of settlers you're going
to know they're really trying to expand
their empire so you'll be like ok I
really need to build my 3rd or 4th city
if I want to take over crucial spots on
the map that they could encroach upon
moving on to combined arms this one's
one of the smaller improvements at we
pick but it is kind of crucial because
you know except 5 unstack the units
units are still for the most part
unstack now when you're attacking a city
you know you'll have your warriors up
front and then your arches behind them
your catapults but now you can combine
certain units so you'll have if you get
a great general a great person who buffs
nearby military units you can just link
him to a warrior squad so they'll travel
together you can
Lincoln anytime there's a little chain
logo it's pretty straightforward on the
menu but then it gets a little more
strategics you'll have like anti-tank
support units with infantry so the tanks
just don't steamroll the infantry like
they normally would the anti-tank will
give them a fighting chance if they're
on the defensive so it's really just
kind of taking back a little bit of the
stacking units that people did miss with
five I personally think it was good to
unstack the units but it's still that
you know strategic approach to taking
cities you know you're lining up your
troops in a certain way but now they
just have more options available so then
the last one we have here is a basically
a multiplayer scenario feature that we
actually didn't get to see we all kind
of played individually in single player
yeah so if you played a civil game
before you know there's certain option
on the main menu to play like a scenario
situations these bite-sized kind of
things where you'll either start with
every advanced technology and just go at
it with other civilizations or you know
just rushed to an economic victory when
you have this amount of gold this is
kind of similar in that no longer do you
only have regular playthroughs and
multiplayer you don't have to sit down
with a few other people for you know
eight hours or whatever funny has to
leave it's all screwed up you have to
save and then reload later now you can
do these like 20 to 30-minute bite sized
things that's just a smaller multiplayer
session so you're not locked into this
long commitment anymore unless you
prefer it that way now they're just
another option for people that don't
have that time yeah like for me I had
had a pretty good time with the game I
would say at some point Ron turned 70 I
was getting a little bored but that
seems like a really cool way to kind of
expedite the process and see you know
you were mentioning obviously with most
of games you know you transfer out of
the stone age and you get into all these
different eras of like human history I
kind of wanted to get those sooner but
again you know some people like the long
form I'm sure of it yeah what you think
overall I came away with really positive
feelings you know it's a bunch of these
improvements that seem minor at first
but actually have these ripple effects
especially unstacking cities that just
changes a ton I'm actually pretty
optimistic about what 4 axis is trying
to do you know there's trying to change
it so each playthrough is different that
sounds cliche and I'm sure if you play
like 200 games you're gonna have similar
games but now they're with active
research with unstacking cities with
these hidden agendas from leaders it's
going to force you out of your comfort
zone more which I'm a huge fan of
because I put about four hundred hours
into civ5 probably at this point in my
lifetime and I have a distinct place out
I always go through I'm a cultural
player I like cultural victories now I'm
not always gonna be able to do that
because if I'm trying to go for a
cultural victory win like the Chinese
Empire is
you know doesn't like me building
wonders it might force me on my comfort
zone if they have reasons to you know be
allies with me I would rather prefer
that it's just going to kind of change
up how I play each time awesome so those
were just some of our main takeaways of
civilization 6 there will be a lot I'm
sure new content down the road the game
comes out october 21st and for all of
your civilization news come to gamespot
com thanks very much Mike thanks Rob
you